the jurogan experience
garrett vandenbush
said this is going to become a pandemic
of variance and he talked about immune
escape
and
that has been very controversial but did
you explain that to people sure what he
argued and let's just say
could you explain who he is too sure he
is a
uh
immunobiologist he is training his
veterinary um he has training in the
relevant area
of vaccination technology
he was a guest on dark horse people can
look up my discussion with him
it is
many people regard it as a very good way
to understand what he's saying because
often he speaks about matters that are
quite technical in any way i
did my best in that podcast to to make
it non-technical so that people could
understand it
in any case what he
argued
was
that the
fact of these vaccines being very
narrowly targeted right these vaccines
contain a single subunit of a single
protein
and they're being deployed in a way that
is unusual they're being deployed into
an active pandemic right when we
immunize against something like measles
the expectation is you will develop your
full immunity with almost no chance of
encountering measles right
in this case what we have are vaccines
that are leaky in which they do not
provide full sterilizing immunity
they are narrow
and
we are effectively creating an intense
evolutionary pressure to cause the spike
protein
of which this one subunit is what is
contained the information for it is
contained in the vaccines we are putting
intense evolutionary pressure on it to
change so that the antibodies and other
immune cell
recognition mechanisms that are trained
by the vaccines are incapable of finding
the pathogen when
it gets in this is what causes
breakthrough cases that the immunity
that's been created is evaded by the
pathogen and if the pathogen changes
that is more likely and so what he said
was
if you vaccinate into an active pandemic
with vaccines like this
what you will get is a
evolutionary pressure for a radiation of
variance an evolutionary radiation of
different
molecular signatures changes in the
spike protein that will then cause the
vaccines to be less and less effective
at producing immunity which is exactly
what we see so he predicted this
absolutely he did predict it accurately
accurate accurately predicted it now is
every component of his model correct
that's a much harder question to answer
but what i would say is any time
somebody succeeds in predicting better
than the so-called experts
you want to know how they did it and
he was making absolute evolutionary
sense right his concerns were very well
honed and he was making sense and then
the world that he predicted emerged and
it is now incumbent on us to say okay
have we learned anything from this right
do the vaccines need to be modified such
that they don't produce this effect
there are conceivable ways you could do
that
right but if we don't do it if we just
say well more of the same have a booster
of the same thing it's not going to
solve the problem so
in effect what i would say is
these vaccines are
a spectacular achievement but they are a
prototype right they have achieved
something that had never been done
before
technologically that's remarkable but
they were not ready for prime time and
they have failed to produce lasting
immunity they have produced very narrow
immunity
it does not compare to the natural
immunity that people get from having had
and beaten the disease and what's more
we have learned an awful lot about how
the disease can be managed so it's much
less lethal right that combination
suggests that we need a rethinking of
our approach
and you know
it is impossible to prove but based on
what people who have successfully
treated the disease and have
successfully predicted events like the
proliferation of variants are telling us
it does seem that we now have the tools
at our disposal to manage this crisis
and do away with it which
i don't know why we don't do that but it
is at least worth noting
that were we to successfully manage it
it would interrupt a
huge flow of revenue into this brand new
pharma
market is that the reason that we don't
do it i don't know but
we the public need to recognize our
interests
are not being served by the public
health apparatus it is making errors
that it doesn't need to make and that
that
has implications for all of our
individual health and our collective
well-being that
require a rethink watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify